I don't know how you could still be
depressed this is probably the best
thing that's ever happened to us
I'm not a carpet I kind of thought that
am I talking too much are they talking
about you money interested I'm not
really interested so I like I'm
interested but I'm not that interested
but I think she might be interested but
do I want to be interested but now she's
not interested how old are you 9 9 you
have a 55 inch plasma TV in your room
on the fire our wine they just got a
punch it in
[Music]
why don't you go enjoy yourself like ice
my balls and spit up blood team player
want to dance rock I want a coke
[Music]
badboo you have no idea in the history
of stupid things on that book cover
I'm the [ __ ] right I'm the [ __ ] I
didn't know the Salvation Army was
having a sale
whose pants are so tight we think I
could see your pardon me balls or your
dangle but I don't
stops right there the continues right
here because I think what my friend
Mitch is trying to say is the true love
is blind and getting five like in a
really weird way here I don't think I've
ever met her before I would definitely
remember this one but you are so money
you don't even know
I don't think you realize what a huge
opportunities those love of guidance is
in your particular situation I'd give
you a hug cominius
[Music]